let's go out to louisville kentucky and
talk to terrence
terrence what's going on man okay thank
you what's up
yes uh how you guys doing today we're
doing outstanding good man
how can we help hey i was trying to see
uh miss o'neill i
read your book with my granddaughter and
uh she's very young now she's only 11
years old but she's motivated
to like start you know doing things now
to to make money i was trying to just
see if you guys could help me brainstorm
on how she could start
raising money now as a young person all
right man that's just
a good question yeah so she's 11 years
old we're trying to figure out how to
start raising money for your
granddaughter
uh right now do you and your on the on
the parents side of thing and
grandparents side of thing do you all
have a 529 already open in her name
no uh and i was talking to uh
her parents really not into that type of
stuff and uh
i think she's gonna be out there
flapping unless i do it so i was trying
to see ways that
i could help her do it uh on her own if
her parents went when doing financial
things
yes so uh terence you can open up a 529
in your daughter's name you will just
need
her social security information um you
wouldn't hear name and social security
so if you can get access to that you can
do that because i have
uh 529's uh my actually my parents
and i have a 529 in the name of my uh
nieces and nephews and so you can do
that now and i will go ahead and start
maxing that out as much as possible so
like when she come over your house
uh grandpa's house have her work around
the house and tell her hey i'm gonna put
some money inside of this account for
you
every time you work so that's one thing
that you should do and jump on it right
now
um how how how's her education process
does she seem like she's going to be
smart going into the middle school in
high school year
yeah yeah very very smart she was uh she
was all into that about the good grades
and uh
applying for scholarships and those type
of things so is that so that's one thing
i would tell her
to really do as a as her grandfather
talk to her a lot about a grade say hey
listen
your grades your academics what you do
in middle school and high school will
determine
uh what school you go to and where you
go
and so when she gets into middle school
i will start having a conversation with
her parents but hey let's get her ready
because he read inside of my book that
free degree right around the eighth
grade she can get inside the duke
program
and so if she can get inside that
program that's going to open up a lot of
scholarships for her
and so i would definitely say focus on
opening up a 529 right now the number
two
make sure that you really have a serious
but fun
uh conversation around her grades making
just making sure that she knows
middle school it starts right here baby
you need all a's
okay you can get one b here but we need
all a's so that way you can go
to her school here's another thing that
has nothing to do with money
and america i want y'all to hear me
because terence asks a great question
um in my book i teach people how to go
uh from the 7th grade up into the 12th
grade on how to get into college debt
free
everyone says well why start so young
well here's the thing john that i
learned one of my homegirls has a school
here in nashville and in elementary okay
in elementary school she does college
visits for fourth and fifth graders
and i said well why and this is
something that you should do with your
granddaughter
take her on a college visit now why so
young anthony she's only 11 years old
well because young people at that age
they are impressionable
so when they walk around this big old
campus you can take them to a community
college and they're going to think that
they're just in heaven like oh this is
so cool
and so as she grows she's going to say
my granddaddy took me to a college and
granddad i want to go back there
granddaddy or mom and dad i want to do
this i want to go to school i want to do
that
why because of what her grandfather did
when she was 11 years old she puts a
picture of what college actually is in
her head
yes she sees young people walking around
it starts to make sense
yes so so terence that's one thing pops
i would do
i would just you know tell tell your
kids hey um i just want to take her on
the college vision
they may say that makes no sense okay
cool that's why i'm not asking y'all to
do it i'ma do it
you know i'ma take her out there and
expose her
if we can expose our young people to
music to
hip-hop videos to the latest dances then
we can expose our young people to
something educational
something informational something that
will change their life
not just make them go viral on instagram
but that can make them go viral in
life because when she comes back i want
to go to school granddad what i got to
do to come here
you need to get good grades okay you
need to focus in class you need to be
obedient to your teacher
you need to listen to your parents and
so i gave you three things that are not
really practical money specific things
uh for your daughter for your
granddaughter to do these are three
things that if you and her parents can
set up and do right now
it would change the trajectory of your
uh
granddaughter's future makes sense
sirens
yes without a doubt thank you so much i
appreciate you guys well hey
i'm gonna throw two more on yeah go
ahead do it number one i want to shout
out
terence and every grandparent
every granddad let's go focus on
granddads
the fact that you were sitting down
reading books to your granddaughter
yeah i tell you what that's legacy
changing in and of itself terence
that's an investment in young people
with your most precious resource that
you can never get back
and that's your time yeah and that is
communicating to this 11 year old girl
that she has
value that she is loved she's got
purpose
granddaddy reads to her man good for you
here's the other thing in addition to
the to the uh anthony i've never even
thought of that
and i love this idea of putting actual
pictures into the hearts and minds of
our kids
terence i want you to raise uh to
co-raise right it sounds like you've got
a lot of influence on that young lady
i want you to let her know that she is
strong
and that she is fierce and that her
opinions
matter and that starts with sometimes
when you talk to her i want you to bend
down
and look her in the eye and say hey how
did that feel
how does that make you did you like that
tell me why you liked it tell me why you
didn't
i want you to be the person this
powerful paternal influence in her life
that teaches her
that her inner voice is strong that
teaches her that her thoughts
and opinions have value to them they
might not always be true
but you're you're you're building these
blocks so that when she shows up at
whatever school
she's going to walk into every class and
know yeah my granddad found value in me
my parents found value to me
i can do hard hard stuff yeah and that
doesn't come in a classroom that comes
from people who love you
who pour into you who aren't just
throwing advice at you all day who
aren't just saying do this to it
saying hey tell me about this because
i'm training somebody how to think how
to how to
own themselves right good for you
terence man that that may be my favorite
call today so far
it is man and i want to say this again
america i want y'all to hear me clearly
this is anthony o'neil saying this
i i get so frustrated bro
when i get on instagram when i get on
facebook and i see parents
celebrating that their daughter knows
the latest hip-hop song
celebrating their daughter or their son
knows the latest
dance that's out there and then they
want to call me
and say hey how do i educate
my kids on this and that it's the same
thing that you're doing
you know you're teaching them you're
allowing them to learn this
no stop that get them off of instagram
get them
off of facebook get them off of youtube
tell them to sit down in front of a
computer screen
and learn and look at colleges learn and
look at how to budget
since my little nephew theo he was our
first my first nephew since he could
walk and talk every time he got around
myself every time he got around his
parents with me
we talked about money christmas last
year i was the first time i sat down and
explained to them hey
this is why your uncle put 1200 inside
of your 529 each one of y'all's 529
because i want to go off to college well
what's a 5 29 uncle anthony come on now
they don't understand anything i'm
saying but they're asking the question
well what is a 529 uncle anthony
i have the conversation and as they get
older
now they're starting to process things
because why when they were a little kid
we started teaching them things ahead of
their time
no five-year-olds should know some
hip-hop dance like that doing it better
than a 30-year-old person but when when
a five-year-old moves and mom lights up
and picks up the camera
then the kid gets the dopamine hit that
says that's what my value is
exactly now if they sit down and have to
listen to another boring lecture from
uncle anthony
what they're going to remember is wait a
minute to change futures you plan way in
advance come on man
you plan way in advance and you have
conversations with people that you want
to hear come on man
my nephew needs to know the difference
in the asset and liability my
they know the difference between a
credit card and a debit card and half of
y'all older people don't even know what
the difference is our federal government
does not know the difference between us
pretty much yeah absolutely right listen
your
everything you do your kids are watching
yeah the kids are learning yes